[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host
and guests not those of this network the
opinions expressed are for
non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned
not to rely on program content to treat
or
prevent disease but are advised to
consult with a licensed health care
professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth
dr joel wallach
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie dr joel wallach your host a
veterinarian
and physician and i'm here for kids and
baby boomers and seniors who don't want
to die at 75.5 like their parents and
grandparents
i'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to be sick and
miserable
the last 15 to 20 years of their life
like their parents and grandparents
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two again that's
nine two five five two
and of course i've been looking for a
long time for some stuff to to
support what i've been saying for over a
year to deal with this covet thing right
now and
they don't have the statistics for today
for the usa but for yesterday
we had 22 million infections in the
united states of covet 19
the pandemic we had 375
000 dead as of yesterday okay we don't
know what it is as of today but
that's pretty bad and of course the the
records show very clearly
and the um johns hopkins came up with
this a year ago and this is what set me
off in this direction
they looked at per 100 000 people with
infections
12 um individuals in asian countries you
know japan and taiwan and south korea
would get the infection 12 out of 100
in asia in italy in the uk
spain and belgium the central europe
kind of thing
um got 349 infections per
100 000 okay and so i said okay well
there's got to be
the diet because you know the asians
live on rice and
people from central europe live on wheat
so that's a gluten thing
and everybody's streaming at me while
like that can't be right that can't be
right
and so you know the numbers came out and
um this uh was out i don't know six
months ago
and i've been repeating it uh it says a
per hundred thousand these are deaths
per hundred thousand
okay uh the indigenous native americans
is 133
okay 133 they have the worst hit and
we're talking about
the um uh alaskan inuits and eskimos as
well as
the native american indian tribes the
blacks are 123.
polynesians are 90 latinos non-mexican
latinos are 86
whites are 75 and the asian americans
are 54.
these are deaths per 100 000 okay and so
that kind of
still goes along with the people who are
eating
gluten-free foods rice and sweet
potatoes did better than people who ate
wheat barley rye and oats then you
compare
hong kong and arizona both have like 7.5
million
people population hong kong has 9 000
infections 157 dead arizona has 607
000 infections and 10 000 dead well
there's a problem
let's look at the uk and thailand both
of them have 67 million people
uk has 3 million infections and 81 000
dead thailand has 10 000 infections in
67 dead
uh i'll give you one more florida and
taiwan 22
million people each florida has
1.5 million infections and 23 000 dead
taiwan has 800 infections and seven dead
the people who are eating rice and sweet
potatoes have an extremely low rate of
deaths and infections compared to people
who eat wheat
barley rye and oats and i've been
looking for that um
when it comes to um you know the native
americans since they have the highest
rate
of infections and deaths in in north
america
uh is kind of crazy so what's going on
there well i finally found it
there's one little indian tribe there's
one little indian tribe
okay and the fondue is called the fond
du lac band
okay of the chippewa or the ojibwe
indians
in northern minnesota they have 3.5
percent
infect positive infections you know
per uh test 3.5 positive tests
um and all the other native americans
have over
you know eight to twelve percent
positive test so
why are these um um indians
from the fond du lac band in
upper minnesota from the ojibwe tribe
why do they have such a low rate
of infections and no deaths no death 3.5
percent
infections per 100 000 but no deaths
well it turns out that all the other
native americans uh
okay live on wheat products okay they
have a flat bread which they
um have it's a universal flatbread
okay and um it's called
barika okay baraka i think it's called
baraka
okay yeah baraka there you go baraka
urbanic no excuse me bannock there it is
bannock
b-a-n-n-o-c-k bannock okay
that's his flat bread that all these
native american indians and it's made
from
wheat and barley wheat and barley
well these ojibwe indians okay
from the fond du lac band they live on
newman they don't live on
bannock like all the other indian tribes
they live on the newman well monument
turns out to be a wild rice grown in the
lakes up there
in northern minnesota no gluten and they
have 3.5 percent
infections on all positive infections
for their tests
but no deaths compared to 8.5 percent
positive infections and the various uh
indian bands around the united states
and they rank number one when it comes
to deaths 133 depending on whose
numbers you look at 133 168 deaths per
hundred thousand
okay and so it's definitely the diet if
everybody were to get off a wheat
brotheranos
live on corn and rice
and sweet potatoes like the asians and
the
ojibwe indians in northern minnesota and
take the 90 essential nutrients
get your immune system going um you are
going to
do very well okay you'll be a survivor
and if you choose to get the vaccination
you're going to get a benefit from it
if you continue to eat wheat barley rye
and oats and don't supplement
you're going to be one of these people
who say well
god why am i here i took the vaccination
how come i died
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs
radio network ever had trouble getting
into the show i do have some open lines
today call us on the priority line
831-685-1080
toll-free
two 888-379-2552 open
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself youngevity's beyond tangy
tangerine
a blend of plant derived minerals
combined with vitamins amino acids
and other beneficial nutrients this
all-natural product contains no starch
wheat or yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives
and it's glycemic friendly each scoop of
the nutri crystals contain equal amounts
of all the nutrients
it starts out as a liquid then is
freeze-dried to ensure
each scoop has the same nutrients as the
last scoop
so if you want to get your hands on a
quality nutritional supplement designed
to give the body the raw materials it
needs to rebuild
youngevities beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count
on the go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this
great multivitamin and mineral product
and don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity aromatherapy oils have been
prized by ancient cultures
for thousands of years youngevity's
ancient legacy true aromatherapy
is no exception essential oils are the
fragrant life essence
from plants that are gently removed
through the process of steam
distillation
youngevity's ancient legacy essential
oils are of the purest concentrations
from the most respected and ethical
distillers worldwide
many of ancient legacy's oils come
directly from families in the east which
have been distilling essential oils
for over 100 years for life's everyday
aches and pains such as sprained ankles
pulled muscles and other bumps and
bruises try agent legacy trauma oil
which contains essential oils
traditionally known to help with pain
swelling and inflammation to learn more
about aromatherapy
and essential oils contact your local
youngevity associate today
and don't forget to ask about business
[Music]
opportunities
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallick
here for young activity 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two
and don't forget you wanna get a hold of
the book in the cd hell's kitchen
it goes into these pandemics going back
way back over a hundred years ago
when there are so many millions of
people dying like crazy because of these
pandemics
and we know i know the reason why of
course
uh and of course is what's catching up
with us now
and again uh it's one of those things
where you look at
um again let's see here let's just pick
one more here let's look at mexico
versus japan both of them have like 127
million people and mexico has 1.5
million infections and 133
000 dead and japan has 273 000
infections and 4 000 dead so what's the
difference so japan lives on rice and
sweet potatoes
and eats um algae and seaweed and stuff
like that and gets a lot of minerals
and the mexicans okay live on wheat
barley rye and oats
and fry everything uh there's a
difference and of course they don't
supplement as a people they're not big
supplementers
and so that's the difference okay i urge
you to
get a hold of your young giving
associate get on drjwalik.com www.dr
and get a hold of the book in the cd
hell's kitchen learn what you need to do
to add 25 to 50 healthier life
learn what you need to do to survive the
pandemic okay and don't forget
these um newman eating
indians up there in northern minnesota
they only have
three three and a half infections per
hundred thousand
and no deaths and that's because they
live on rice they live on rice like
asians
oh my gosh okay let's see here
doug what pearl's wisdom they have for
us today well i think this one
vindicates you
as ever since i've known you you've
abdicating eating real butter as opposed
to things like margarine and i've got a
story here headlined
stick to the real thing natural foods to
eat
instead of margarine said for a long
time government and health organizations
have advocated margarine as a way to
cooking
uh to avoid the negative effects of
butter
and it turns out the reverse is actually
true well you and i
knew that they say in fact that may
cause more harm to the body
than a butter mite and they say what is
margarine they say it can be traced back
to france where it was developed by a
chemist
hippolyte mega maurice in response to
emperor napoleon iii's call for the
development of a cheap
butter alternative his original mixture
consisted of beef tallow churned with
milk
and then was unchanged until the 1930s
when the depression
forced manufacturers to use vegetable
oils such as soybean and safflower
since then margin has become widely used
as an alternative to butter
often marked as quote the healthier
choice
they say a negative effects of margin on
the body margin is actually linked to
several health risks most of which are
caused by its manufacturing process a
butter like consistency and higher
melting temperature is due to a process
kite
called hydrogenation and the
introduction of hydrogen molecules into
oils renders the oils stable
at room temperature ensuring a long
shelf life
hydrogenation is also a result creation
of trans fats and research
has linked increased risk of heart
disease and other health issues
aside from raising the risk of heart
disease and other cardiovascular
problems there are other health problems
associated with margarine
it's packed with bad fats such as
soybean canola palm and safflora
oils and we know we don't like oils in
addition it's being sold
in a market it has high in omega-6 fatty
acids
which are linked to diseases such as
diabetes obesity cancer irritable bowel
syndrome and arthritis
also lacks essential vitamins and
minerals while butter
it has vitamins a k and e as well as
several minerals and other nutrients
that are good for you so there you go
you're vindicated again doc
yeah and you know that stuff costs money
so don't throw it away if you have like
a six month supply of margin in your
freezer refrigerator give it to your
doctor okay
but this is why you need to get a hold
of the books hell's kitchen
a kitchen can be a place of heaven or
hell depending what you do in there
so the book in the cd hell's kitchen it
goes back to three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882
when thomas edison and jonathan leaves
pulled the switch on the first
commercial electric generating plant
no more wood ashes for mineral source
and fertilizer gardens
we had lots of electricity back after
these messages
you're listening to dead doctors
don't lie on the cbs radio network with
your host
dr joel wallick if you ever had trouble
getting in i do have some open lines
today call us on the toll-free line
888-379-2552 that's
triple eight 379-2552
lines open
[Music]
if weight loss is your goal try
youngevity slender fx keto caramel
weight management bars
and shake designed to enhance any low
carbohydrate or low glycemic diet
by supplying the energizing and filling
protein dieters need
without unhealthy excess carbs a keto
diet
known for its low carb intake pushing
the body to produce
ketones from fat used as
energy a state known as ketosis
by using fat not carbohydrates as fuel
in this metabolic state a keto diet
supports and promotes
healthy weight management for optimal
health
with this system you should be able to
lose one
to two pounds each day
so what are you waiting for start
helping people today
with your own home-based business hey if
you're like me
your life is hectic you don't know where
you're gonna be next between kids
and family and in-laws and work and
traffic and everything else that's
driving me crazy right now
my life is insane i bet your life's
insane as well when do we have time to
get every single nutrient we need to be
healthy when
well i've got a tip for you take a
product called pollen burst
it's so simple even i can do it all you
have to do is open the package
pour it in water mix it up and bam
you're ready to go
it tastes great it's not one of those
medicine tasting things it tastes great
low in calories helps curb your appetite
gives you natural energy that doesn't
let you crash
gives you your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and i got to tell you
for a busy person like me or a busy
person like you we need
simple we need good palm versus your
answer
taste great try it and you'll feel
better call your local youngevity
distributor to find out how pollenverse
can make you feel better
and don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr wallach and youngevity
products
have changed their lives if you're now
convinced that dr wallach is on to
something
and you want to try yogevity's premium
quality products for yourself
we can connect you with a distributor
that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallach
here for young activity 90 flag crusade
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's
toll free one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two
and don't forget to get a hold of that
book in that cd hell's kitchen
and learn how to deal with all this okay
and um
i just am breathless here because of
course
doug will be posting this
episode of dead doctors don't lie as it
usually does so you need to get this and
get it to your local newspapers
your local radio stations because i've
figured out and have the proof now
unimpeachable proof is the gluten issues
is causing so much trouble
uh in peoples uh who are not asian okay
and
also gluten issues in our
indigenous populations who live on
everything you know like this
uh bannock this flat bread and the
one tribe that lives on
manumen okay newman which is a rice
wild rice they have the lowest rate of
infections and no deaths
uh uh okay charmaine
hello hello charmaine can you hear me
i'm here i can hear you i can hear you
now you're kind of silent there for a
minute
okay all right now you've been with me
for a long time and you've seen us get
rid of diseases like muscular dystrophy
and sediment death syndrome and cystic
fibrosis and stuff like that
and arthritis and and celiac disease and
eczema
alzheimer's disease i mean we've got rid
of all those things using a a youngevity
program and supplements and diet and so
forth
and so um are you surprised
that i finally i mean i stayed up all
night last night going through every
indian tribe okay on the internet
all the records and everything i finally
found
this little this little fond du lac band
of indians
from the chippewa aka ojibwe indians in
northern
minnesota not too far west of you
and they have the lowest rate of
infections
positive infections from testing and no
deaths
compared to all the other indian nations
that have like three times the
infections and have the worst death rate
of any
race races in the united states and so
it's just unimpeachable evidence to back
up everything we've been saying here for
the last year and a half
and so um what's what's your opinion
here
well it makes sense i mean once you
learn
it makes common sense
yeah once you know yeah yeah once you
know the language of the tissue it makes
sense and of course
all these people getting the
vaccinations they're going to have
a wide variety of responses because if
they're living on gluten
they're not going to have a very good
response to the vaccinations
vaccinations do not kill
bacteria and viruses and fungus they
just alert your body and your immune
system
to the dna rna and
protein from these bugs but if you don't
have the ability to absorb
nutrients and get them into your bone
marrow to make white blood cells and
antibodies you cannot respond
to the bugs even if you've been
vaccinated so i'm predicting here it's a
horrible prediction
but there's going to be so many people
who are vaccinated are still going to
die
from the pandemic they're going to be
horribly sick from the pandemic
say well how come my husband died he was
vaccinated
he even had a second dose and he died to
the pandemic
well that's because he was still eating
gluten and couldn't absorb nutrients
and so there was no nutrients getting
into his bone marrow so the bone marrow
couldn't make white blood
cells and antibodies
shawn and i will be back after these
messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs
radio network with your host dr joel
wallach if you'd like to talk to dr
wallach call us toll free
888-379-2552 that's
triple eight three seven nine two five
five
two lines open
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr wallach and youngevity
products have
changed their lives if you're now
convinced that dr wallach is on to
something
and you want to try yogevity's premium
quality products for yourself
we can connect you with a distributor
that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463 hi this is dr joel wallick
your host of dead doctors don't lie
if you're interested in a colon cleanse
blood cleanse liver cleanse you know in
the classical herbal way
you want to ask your youngevity
associate for herbal rainforest herbal
rainforest has
16 herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs
and 77 plant minerals that's right and
these are all organic it doesn't get
any better than that and your busy day
and you're around all these toxins out
there in your workplace on the way home
going to work in your food in the air
in the water you need herbal rainforest
i guarantee you
it will give you a cleanse you can
control the dose it's a liquid
it tastes good it doesn't get any better
than this a
colon that's happy makes you happy
nothing better than a happy colon
herbal rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about on the dead doctors
don't lie radio program
call your local youngevity associate
today and don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities
greetings everyone judy de vilbis here
what do you think of when you hear the
words
tangy tangerine well i think of
like a sweet tangy tasting something
well what i'm referring to
is the ultimate tangy tangerine it's a
fantastic product it has everything you
need and a great benefit
is it's very very delicious it's very
easy to drink
i've suggested it even to youngsters
even children like it even little guys
even little girls they come right into
my office their parents can't get them
to take those chewables and besides that
they're not as good as tangy tangerine
and i give them a little taste of that
and you know something they're pleased
as punch
so if it's good for a child and it
tastes delicious
why not you there's no excuse not to
take a vitamin when it tastes as good as
that does so how about it tangy
tangerine should be the answer to all of
your nutritional program problem
for more information or to order call
your youngevity distributor today
and don't forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
this is the zbs radio network network
network
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the cbs radio network dr joel wallick
here for youngevity ninety flight
crusade we do have lines open
give us call toll free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two again
that's
toll free one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two
and again uh i want to compare a
homogeneous country to a homogenous
country india
okay uh they're pretty much the same
people 1.4 billion people the second
largest population in the world next
only to china
they have 10 million 10.5 million
infections
150 000 dead and
95 percent of the deaths occur
in the top northern nine states of india
five percent of the deaths occur in the
southern uh
20 states and the seven territories
86 percent of the infections occur in
the nine
northern states and only 14 of the
infections occur in the 20
southern states and the seven
territories
so what's the difference between
northern india
and southern india same people same
religion same everything oh
one difference the northern
um nine states live on wheat
and the southern 20 states and seven
territories live on
rice and sweet potatoes like asians and
so that's just another testimony to show
you
that um it's no doubt to gluten so
everybody's got to give up gluten
and i just am so excited about finding
out this menuman story here
with the ojibwe indians in northern
minnesota
okay they have the lowest rate
of positive tests of the
um pandemic when it comes to all the
um you know the native tribes the
indians the indigenous peoples and so
forth
and no deaths well everybody else you
know is eating
that bannock that flatbread made from
wheat and barley
okay gluten alert gluten alert gluten
alert whereas
these ojibwe indians are eating a
rice product called menumen it's a wild
rice that grows there
very uniquely in northern michigan
so there's no doubt about it and again
this will be posted
and so everybody can forward this to
your local newspapers your local radio
stations your local churches your family
this needs to get out there because
this is unimpeachable evidence
okay let's see here doug we got time to
start a caller
yeah we certainly do let's head to north
carolina
and alvin you're on with dr wallach
hello alvin
you're on the air
hello i can't hear you i cannot hear you
okay can you hear me now oh that's
better okay
all right yes i'm having trouble with
my balance oh
i missed that you heard you haven't okay
you're turning away from the phone or
something because
i have trouble with and then i didn't
hear it
well balance
okay let me ask you a question let me
let me ask you a question do you have
any tinnitus or ringing in the ears kind
of that
noise no
okay do you have any irregular heartbeat
atrial fibrillation
tachycardia fast heart rate bradycardia
slow heart rate anything like that
nobody got me on three blood pressure
medicine okay
do you have any hiccups
no what do you weigh alvin what's your
body weight
how old are you before
okay and so you have high blood pressure
you have any diabetes
sorry what do i have
okay so pre-diabetes kind of thing okay
okay
charmaine what would you do for alvin
here he's 200 pounds
um you know he's being treated for high
blood pressure he's a pre-diabetic
and he has some uh back issues when we
come back
get your pen and paper ready alvin
because charmaine and i will give you a
protocol here
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie
we do have some open lines today call us
on the toll-free line 888-379-2552
that's
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two and you'll be talking to dr
wallach
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian dr joel wallick helped many
people on the dead doctors don't lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr
wallach and youngevity products have
changed their lives
if you're now convinced that dr wallach
is on to something and you want to try
yogevity's premium quality products for
yourself
we can connect you with a distributor
that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
i am judy de vilvas here i am speaking
to you again i just wanted to tell you
that recently
i started drinking the way shakes again
the chocolate way shake
and you need to remember the whey shake
isn't just
for losing weight it's a fantastic place
to get your great protein
and if you're trying to gain weight you
can take it along with your meals
and the best part is if you want to just
have a great protein
shake do like i do put it over ice stir
it up and you can sip on it for 20
minutes
to an hour i do it every single day i
absolutely love it you need to get back
to it too it's really good for you and
it makes
not fat but it makes muscle after you
work out and you can also
mix it up in a blender with an egg and
you have the most incredible
health protein shake or mix it with a
little water stir it up and you have a
little pudding
and who doesn't like pudding for more
information
or to order call your youngevity
distributor today
and don't forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on this eds radio network dr joel wallet
care for young jimmy 90 flight crusade
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine
two five five two and just to add to
that uh you know announcement we're
looking
to start some more uh businesses here if
you're remotely interested
you get the wholesale prices and the
products whether you're a customer or an
associate
if you get on auto ship whether you're a
customer associate i pay the shipping so
you're going to save a lot of money
there because these are liquids are kind
of heavy to ship
and then um also when you sign up it's a
to be a business builder it's a 50 um
entry fee to get your franchise you have
to renew every year for 50 bucks
but when you first sign up and every
year you renew for that 50 bucks not
only does it continue to be
tax a tax deductible 50 bucks but also
i will give you each time each time you
renew your franchise and when you first
sign up
i will give you 500 bucks free worth
of business building materials i mean i
don't know how to make any better than
that
okay doug let's go right back to north
carolina
and alvin and charmaine what would you
do for alvin again he's 200 pounds 74
years old
he's got some back issues he's a
pre-diabetic he's got high blood
pressure and
what would you do for him well basically
because of his weight
well first of all he needs to get on a
gluten-free diet no wheat
barley rye or oats no fried foods no
oils of any kind and no burnt animal fat
then
because of his weight he needs two packs
i would get him on a healthy
bone and joint pack and i'd get him on a
healthy brain and hard pack and i would
add to it
ultimate daily classic or the blood
flow problem and vitamin d3 for
absorption and some msm for
just for rebuilding connective tissue
yeah yeah
and then and those things together with
a healthy diet
will uh what would you what would you
have them take for you know what would
you yeah what would you have him drink
for energy
rebound of course well rebound yeah it's
the only sports drink out there that's
actually designed for professional
athletes olympic athletes
and it's got a hundred nutrients in it
everybody else has got two nutrients and
a lot of sugar and caffeine ours has a
hundred nutrients and it's 78 of which
are minerals
wow give us a call every couple of weeks
we're going to want to know
you know what's going on if you go to a
doctor between now and then let us know
what the doctor says
we'll walk you through this alvin okay
doug
let's go to callers all right let's head
to tampa florida and rodney you're on
with dr wallach
hello rodney you're on the air
got two questions for you yes sir hello
yes sir i got two questions for you one
question
uh you told me to get the uh one healthy
uh heart and brain pack per month and
take
half of everything but how do you take
half of how much
what are you weighing what do you weigh
i weigh a 100 pounds but the ef8
is a jail
and yeah but see it right now okay yeah
yeah we'll stop
okay and so it it in one healthy brain
and heart pack there's gonna be a bottle
so
you can take three of those capsules a
day and so
um one day i would take one the next day
take two the next day take one the next
day take two
okay that's easy so it'll average out
you know one and a half
per day okay so what's the second
question
the efa and the ef-8 plus are those
this is not my second question but i was
trying to include this in the first
the esa and the esa plus do i take
one of those as well or are they the
same yeah that's correct
no they're not the same char what's the
difference between the efas and the f8
pluses
the fa pluses has same as the efa only
it's
got added a fish oil to it yeah well the
the source of the efa plus
is fish liver oil the source of the efas
and the efas is from seeds you're
getting it from two different
areas and so they have a little bit of a
different uh
action okay but um
you want to take one of each
um one day the next day take two of each
okay this is not difficult okay second
question
second question uh my eyes have been
swollen
ever since uh my kid expelled and i was
taking anti-rejection
medicine i want to know um taking your
products
with my eyes go back down or wild
okay okay now when you say swollen are
you talking about
your eyeball is swollen and your
pressure's up you have glaucoma or are
you talking about your eyelids
underneath my eyes i guess
um the lower eyelid
yeah um okay it's just swollen from the
anterior rejection medication they told
me it would happen
yeah okay and so charmaine what would
you what would you have him kind of
apply to that swelling underneath his
eye
and um well he could
he could uh use the same cream with some
trauma oil in it but he's got to be
careful not to get it in his
eye okay i just swipe down
instead of up and down and then let's
see here also
um he's one that would do well with the
msm and vitamin d3 and all that other
stuff
because it's going to um how old are you
rodney i'm 31 with kidney failure so i'm
assuming it's related to the kidney
okay okay so you're on dialysis right
yeah okay so what would you give him for
the dialysis sherman
well he i don't know how much he weighs
but for every 100 pounds of body weight
he needs a healthy brain
and heart pack and he needs to add to
that ultimate daily classic
because yeah okay now he weighs wait a
minute okay stop stop he weighs 100
pounds
so i would have him take since he's got
all these symptoms i would have him take
two bottles a month of the ultimate
daily classic tablets
take two with each meal be a total of
six a day and that's going to support
healthy blood pressure it's going to
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries
whether they're in your eye outside your
eye in your kidneys and a lot of times
we take people who've been on dialysis
for 10
years and they haven't urinated for
those 10 years they're on dialysis six
days a week their own dialysis 15
years before that because they didn't
want to get a kidney transplant
and so then just after two weeks in the
program you're getting they start
urinating
after 10 years of not urinating so they
reduced their dialysis from six days a
week down to three
and then after two more weeks they were
totally off the dialysis after 25 years
on dialysis
but you have to use kind of a heavy
hammer here because
the odds are you got blocked arteries in
your kidneys that's why your kidneys
aren't working very well
that's why the blood pressure goes up
and that's why you might have swelling
um you know underneath your eyes is
because you have edema because your
circulation is bad
and all your blood vessels so give us a
call every couple of weeks give us a
call when you go see the doctor let us
know what they say
and we'll walk you through this rodney
but we have a lot of experience
dealing with people with your issues
okay doug let's go to callers or emails
all right i've got an email here from
nokia and who is five foot eight 160
age 30 has ringing in the ears and i
found this a little in
uh inconsistent because it says no skin
problems that has
asthma and dermatitis as well as
cirrhosis
also has some abscess teeth and has some
teeth
with fillings falling out also says that
they have trouble swallowing pills would
hope you could recommend liquids rather
than tablets or pills
okay charmaine
yeah this individual machia and it
sounds
japanese to me got tinnitus ringing in
the ears 160 pounds
um has dermatitis but no skin problems i
find that funny like
doug did tonight is ringing in the ears
yeah
and and so what what's going on here
she's got osteoporosis of the skull for
one thing and she's also got a
gluten problem for sure because that's
what's causing all these skin problems
gluten and the asthma yeah and the
respiratory stuff yeah
absolutely and so what would you do what
would you give her
well she needs to get on a gluten-free
diet no wheat
barley rye or oats no
oils of any kind and no burnt animal fat
and no
fried foods then did she need quickly
yeah i would get her on uh i'd get
around one healthy brain and hard pack
and one healthy bone and joint pack and
i would add to it ultimate daily classic
msm vitamin d3 for absorption and
those things should take care of okay
give us again
call and contact us every couple of
weeks no nokia we'll be back after these
messages
and if you'd like to talk to dr wallach
i do have open lines call me at
two five five 8388-379-2552 that's
triple eight three seven nine
two five five two lines open you'll be
getting right on with dr wallach
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
earth's oceans
we do know that the oceans and seas are
still abundant with life
and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures
have long believed in the life-giving
properties of plants
and sea life harvested from the oceans
youngevities ocean's gold is a
proprietary blend
of seaweeds algaes mosses kelp
sea cucumbers and sea minerals as well
as coenzyme q10
calcium and iron all designed to help
support healthy
thyroid function regular heartbeat
normal weight
mood stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage
of life-sustaining nutrients from the
earth's oceans
with youngevities oceans gold if you'd
like to learn more about nutritional
supplementation
call your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities in recent years
several studies have discovered the
health benefits of drinking
coffee youngevity has now taken it a
step further with an entire product line
of healthy coffees
from youngevity's java fit selection of
top
shelf gourmet coffees all java fit
coffees are made from 100
premium and selected arachaba coffee
beans grown in the finest regions of
latin america
all carefully roasted creating a
delicious rich full-bodied flavor
try java fit's immune plus a full robust
coffee blend combined
with the immune supporting benefits of
echinacea and the full spectrum daily
requirement of vitamins and minerals
boost your immune system every day with
java fits immune plus
multivitamin coffee available in 30
count single cup
or 24 count single pot packs contact
your local youngevity distributor to get
job evolution coffees
and don't forget to ask about the
home-based business opportunity you've
listened to physician and veterinarian
dr
joel wallick helped many people on the
dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr wallach and youngevity
products
have changed their lives if you're now
convinced that dr wallach is on to
something
and you want to try yogevity's premium
quality products for yourself
we can connect you with a distributor
that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 313-444-3463
that's 313-444-3463
call now to change your life that's
313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the zds radio network dr joel wallach
here for youngevity 95 crusade
and doug let's go to callers or emails
all right i've got another email here
this one's from maryland she has been
on youngevity for about seven years uh
67 years old
five eight 140 pounds was diagnosed with
diverticulitis
has been gluten free ever since then
tries to stay away from the
the bad foods but does have acidy
stomach and heartburn as well as
belching
and bloat bloating and has to uh
evacuate that uh forcefully and also uh
claims she has no other health issues
so what would you have that her do
okay charmaine what's going on with her
she's got belching and burping and
bloating
she's got him she's she needs stomach
acid so
yeah yeah she can well okay well she
weighs 140 pounds what would you give
her give her give her the basics here
which what does she need
well she's on the cost but whether she
needs but i would get around the house
i would get around the healthy green and
hard pack and i'd get her on some
uh ultimate
classic daily classic and i would also
get around some msm
and that should cover all the options
all the possibilities
yeah well she needs to you know she
needs the open enzymes of course before
she's
needs to take enzymes yeah she needs our
ultimate enzyme to
take two of those say two to five
minutes for each meal with a couple
ounces of water
and um uh this could be a squeezing
of the tenth cranial nerve the vagus
nerve
okay it's called gastroparesis okay
gastroparesis um and
um it's one of those things and see here
um and she has diverticulitis so that
could be
she's maybe giving some gluten in there
somewhere but
it's absolutely imperative okay that she
takes some msm along with it some
vitamin d3
some extra glucogen because i believe
she also has 67 years of age she got
osteoporosis the skull squeezing
the um uh 10th training nerve which
should give her symptoms of a
diverticulitis but also certainly give
her
digestive issues bloating and burping
and belching and belly pain and so forth
so in addition to all the things
associate also needs the msm vitamin d3
and so forth and rebuild her skull
and she needs to email us and contact us
every couple of weeks
and give us a status report when she
goes to the doctor we need to know what
the doctor says
because i think this is all reversible
stuff i mean i deal with these things
you know literally by the thousands
every month all over the world
everybody tells the same story but if
they do the same thing properly
it all goes away this is not a genetic
thing but these pre-existing conditions
will put you in in a position
where if you do get exposed to the
pandemic bug
guess what you're going to have a high
risk of infection you're going to have a
high risk of a
not so good outcome because you're not
being able to absorb
nutrients to get to the bone marrow to
be able to make white blood cells and
antibodies and red blood cells and
platelets
so just remember that vaccines do not
kill bugs they just alert your body to
the bad
dna rna and and proteins of bugs whether
it's a virus of fungus or bacteria
but you have to be ready to respond
when the bug shows up with antibodies
and white blood cells and red blood
cells and platelets but if you don't
have
nutrition going to your bone marrow
that's not going to happen so i predict
there's going to be an
extremely variable outcome of all these
vaccinations that's going on for this
current
pandemic that's going on some people are
going to have some pretty nice
outcomes i predict it's going to be the
people who are eating like asians
okay whether it's the ojibwe indians or
it's the japanese americans
or people you know who are eating
gluten-free foods or eating rice and
sweet potatoes and stuff like that
they're going to have the best benefit
from vaccinations
the ones who continue to eat gluten and
don't supplement they're going to have
the worst possible result
from the vaccination which means they're
not going to see benefit
and the bug could kill them even though
they've been vaccinated
and so this is you know a threefold
process here
and of course um you know we have
been cheated okay for a year and a half
we were told just wash your hands wear a
mask
distance yourself everything would be
fine but what did we get for doing that
for a year and a half well we got 22
million infections
and 375 000 dead i mean it just makes
you want to scream and pull your hair
out
this is the worst possible income except
for the entire country burning down
well thank you so much everybody great
calls and emails thank you so much to
our main super job as usual
thank you doug super job as usual god
bless each and every one of you god
bless your troops god bless
your navy seals god bless the american
flag god bless your national anthem
and god bless america
[Music]
wow